ava, qu'est-ce que
tu fous ici
oh mon dieu c'est tellement génial de te voir
tu es toujours aussi belle
puis-je
ma sœur incroyable tu m'as manqué as-
tu reçu mon message je pense que j'aurais pu
avoir un rêve oh comme c'est cool  ça a marché il
y a ton action effrayante à distance
ouais et bien action effrayante de toute façon de quoi
parlez-vous les gars vous
savez que c'est très pas de chance de
franchir un seuil sans être invité
avez-vous toujours peur de l'ail
je ne parle pas de mythes ici ava
tu sais, c'est aussi une malchance d'écouter
la musique privée de quelqu'un sans
invitation oh mon dieu je l'adore, c'est
totalement génial, puis-je
télécharger non
donc
tu es juste de passage à Détroit ouais non
je veux dire je suis venu te voir
j'ai été  vivant à Los Angeles, un
super
centre de zombies,
êtes-vous seul
non, je
suis ici avec vous, [ __ ],
vous ne pouvez pas rester ici,
[ __ ], pas la dernière fois,
Adam, ça fait 87 ans,
et
quand
es-tu toujours énervé à propos du truc de Paris ?